would you find uh well his record goes  back way before with the Federation even  existed he was a major in the United us  military assault command operation lot  of offworld combat he was a soldier why  has he not used his weapon yet he wants  to find somewhere to inflict maximum  damage click on the planet  he needs a distribution deal heezy  we need a distribution deal oh we have  one he needs a three-picture deal with  her heart worse Santa ever heard oh yeah  my name is James Tiberius Kirk of the  United Federation of Planets I'm  appearing before you as a neutral  representative of the feminine but fo  Bowen Pabon n' I'm appearing before you  as a neutral representative of the fabin  Onan as a neutral representative of the  fo Bonin captain King house they're  happy  must represent some  there's some sort of future global  transport food and they lieutenant  there's sorry weird noises up